nous ça nous arrivait à un seuil où le
nombre de victimes du confinement est
supérieur au nombre de victimes du coc
vide exactement c'est à dire que les
gens meurent aujourd'hui non plus du
virus mais des essais du virus
collatéraux c'est à dire de rester chez
soi de ne pas pouvoir rencontrer des
amis d' asphyxie culturel et
intellectuel est aussi sociale das fixie
social genevois on nous dit toute la
journée on peut pas choisir les victimes
tout le monde doit être soignée mais
tout le monde doit essayer d'être soigné
d'une seule chose du coc vide car tous
ceux qui n'ont pas le comité sont priés
d'attendre que leur maladie les laisse
tranquilles et laisse les hôpitaux
tranquille parce que le copine n'est pas
dangereux ce sont les hôpitaux qui sont
asphyxiés c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose eric le docteur l'a dit d'ailleurs
très honnêtement à deux reprises et je
crois qu'il n'a pas dit inconsciemment
mais consciemment
il nous parle d'abord d' asphyxie des
hôpitaux et ensuite de santé publique
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose si
on regarde vraiment au microscope on est
dans une situation où de fait on a
choisi de privilégier je dis bien de
privilégier les gens qui étaient malades
de la seule maladie à la mode en ce
moment quelques vides mais ce que mon
cancer ce qu'on alzheimer sont conclues
rose en plaques sont priés de ne pas
déranger les hôpitaux qui sont
surchargés se mélange à tout cela
s'ajoute à tout cela tous ceux qui
deviennent malades du confinement les
maladies psychiatriques
les jeunes qui m'arrêtent dans la rue
tous les jours pour que je continue à
véhiculer cette parole parce que ils
sont à deux doigts de se pendre à se
défenestrer
et je ne plaisante pas c'est avéré on a
des cas de suicides chez des enfants de
moins de 15 ans si cela ne relève pas de
la santé publique
si les médecins continuent à ne vouloir
regarder que le coc vide et que
l'apocalypse qui est tout autour ne les
intéresse pas s'il préfère regarder
quelqu'un qui se fait une entorse sur le
trottoir mais comme tous les morts
autour qui s'amoncellent ne les
intéresse pas ils sont responsables à
leur tour et d'une certaine manière il
entérine une sorte d' assassinat
collectif qui est un axe e sina sociale
car finalement aujourd'hui nous avons
privilégié les malades du que vides par
rapport aux malades tout court et
j'appelle tous les étudiants à se
révolter contre un confinement globale
si jamais il y en a un nouveau oui à se
révolter jeunesse à tour indigne
obéissant civique puissante car le mot
même de confinement je nous donne
aujourd'hui
appel à la désobéissance est obligé de
rouler s'élargit à chagrine c'est à
chaud c'est pas ça ils vont discuter du
problème
je représente la chaîne n'était pas la
position d'alger le dimanche n'est pas
là aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la réalité
du confinement qui donne la nausée c'est
simplement le mot le mot donne des
nausées et même des maladies
psychosomatiques à certains il ya des
étudiants qui sont entre la vie et la
mort aujourd'hui j'ai encore de
questions à poser donc karim est ensuite
nos deux habitants avec moi le la
conviction qui est la mienne c'est que
on ne peut avoir qu'une certitude malgré
nos positions ici c'est que nul ne peut
avec certitude avancée la solution
magique c'est ça depuis le début de la
crise que nous soyons médecin citoyen
lambda hommes politiques économistes
on se rend bien compte que ce dont nous
discutons c'est plutôt quelle est la
solution la moins pire
et là moi ma position si elle est
négative c'est parce que j'essaye de
faire le rapport entre la balance des
bénéfices et des risques montent quand
j'entends les médecins on nous avait
expliqué fréquemment que c'est au sein
de la cellule infra et rafa milliards
que la contagion était la plus rapide et
la plus importante qu'est ce que
provoque un confinement si ce n'est le
regroupement des familles en fermer en
leur sein et donc une propagation du
virus plus rapide que si effectivement
on avait des interactions avec des
distanciation le port du masque
moi j'ai entendu dire aussi par les
effets collatéraux du confinement qu'il
y avait des dégâts monumentaux sur la
santé mentale sur les violences faites
aux femmes sur les enfants violentés
nous en avons parlé au fond cette
émission on peut pas faire comme si ça
n'existait pas donc sauver des vies par
la simple approche de l'aco vide mais
générer je dirais des drames
ddd mort d'une autre manière je pense
qu'il ya un équilibre à trouver
et cette balance doit être fait avec la
plus grande
je dirais et lucidité or aujourd'hui on
ne peut avoir une approche sanitaires
qui se limite à la colline
9la proches sanitaire 1 elle doit être
plus large et 2 1 ne peut pas être leur
fait d'une décision politique
parce que la politique c'est un spectre
plus large que la seule question
sanitaire
la politique c'est les interactions
sociales économiques culturelles c'est
la possibilité pour des étudiants de
pouvoir parce que ce sont les
populations qui sont les moins touchées
même si vous nous avez indiqué des
chiffres de personnes qui étaient donc
moins âgés et qui étaient touchés
on sait très bien que 93 % de la
mortalité cd 65 ans et plus ça veut dire
qu'on ne peut pas mettre sous cloche
l'ensemble d'une population l'ensemble
de ce secteur d'activité quand
j'entendais dans son reportage avant de
venir quand même une fleuriste
maintenant j'en termine par là un
fleuriste de nice qu'on ne qualifiait
pas comme une économie et saint-michel
allait fermer l coiffeur de même parce
que ç'a l'air confiné 60 et 18% de son
chiffre d'affaires et fait le week-end
comment fait-il je pense qu'à un moment
donné quand on mesure le bénéfice des
risques et je dirais des avantages pour
moi le qu'aucune mans il faut l'éviter à
tout prix